Oh
so in a recent video we did on radical
openness we talked about the importance
of technology as something that creates
new possibilities in the world
technology acts as a kind of cognitive
scaffolding that extends the reach of
our agency it extends our possibilities
outwards beyond the biological skin
tissue and it also unearths new
modalities of artistry languages of
human subjectivity new ways to narrate
human becoming the becoming of the
imagination of the subjective
perspective imagine how impoverished the
world would have been if we didn't have
the technology of oil painting in time
for van Gogh's genius to unfurl or how
impoverished the world would have been
if we didn't have the musical instrument
technology in time for Beethoven's
genius Beethoven's voice to be burst
through that prism new technologies new
modalities new possibilities